So I started as a pilot
in the Israeli Air Force,
which is a very entrepreneurial place.
When I finished that, I started my
first company and like many of them,
it was not very successful.
And then I started my second company
which luckily was more successful which
I sold many years ago,
talking about close to 20 years ago now.
After that I started my
journey to the dark side and
moved to become an executive in
the company that acquired my company.
Moved on there up to being a CEO, then
became the CEO of another company and
then built another company.
Last company I ran for
five years was a publicly traded company
in London called 888 Gaming Company.
Around 1500 people
dealing with internet and
started investing in companies or
11 years ago as a hobby.
A friend came to me with
an idea I really like the idea.
I gave him a bit of money and
the lot of advice and then after a year,
I got a big fat check and
I said well I can do that.
I love that.
And so I took all that money and
I decided I'm going to reinvest it in
other companies and I was very lucky
in that some of the companies I chose
became more successful and
so I continued with it.
And so over the years,
I invested in quite a few companies.
And then when I left my last corporate
role five years ago, I decided that it's
going to be a good idea to not take
another big ugly corporate role and
instead of it just stick to
the entrepreneurship and investments.
And that's what I've been
doing the last five years.